hello you're watching the daily climate
show on
sky news on today's programme
nato leaders agree to make climate
change a top priority as it risks
threatening
global security we look at how the uk's
leading tech firms are working together
to achieve
net zero emissions and the leader
working with young people to build
sustainable communities
in central america
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show
where we track the changes happening to
our world right now
and we meet those who are developing the
solutions
well nato leaders have met in brussels
today and while china and russia were
top of the agenda for the first time
climate change was also a priority
rising temperatures and extreme weather
have caused instability
across the world and there are concerns
global warming has become a threat
to transatlantic security so why has
climate become
such a pressing issue for the military
alliance
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well joining me now is nizarin elsaim
she's climate activist and chair of un
secretary general's
youth advisory group on climate security
a very good afternoon
to you nizreen we were looking there at
some of the global
threats to security which come through
climate change i know you're from sudan
talk us through the security threats to
the parts of the world
like your country thank you very much
samantha and
indeed for sudan it's not a matter of
science or
papers or documents it's something that
we are living actually
every day of our life um i mean
nowadays it's everything is very much
intense because of the climate crisis
that we are having
uh uh in 2007 the previous um
u.n secretary general mentioned the
conflict in darfur
and uh described it as the first climate
conflict
in the recent days and unfortunately
things are not stopping at that time
you've got a very prominent position
haven't you um
chair of the un secretary general's
youth advisory group it's been the young
people hasn't it who've really been
driving home awareness and the messaging
do you have confidence that people with
the financial and indeed
military might are listening
well unfortunately they will not have a
choice in a very
very soon time uh all what we are trying
to do as young people is we don't want
to reach the
limit of breaking down we want to try as
much as possible to
save what's left from our environment
and our planet
and of course we are very much concerned
about our future and the next
generation's future
i guess young people are in the front
line of the climate action
not only because we have no other
solution but because we see
we see things as pure as it is
business as usual is not going to work
climate change is going to impact
everyone and every aspect of life and
the covet 19 was a very small test
of what nature can actually do of us if
we did not take actions now
thank you very much for your time
nazarene great to talk to you thank you
well let's take a look at some of the
day's other climate news now
and electricity generated from wind
power in the uk
has increased by 715
since 2009 with the national grid saying
that 2020 was the greenest year on
record well according to latest figures
from the office for national statistics
wind energy generation
accounted for 24 of total electricity
generated in 2020
and last year the uk generated enough
electricity to power 8.4
trillion led light bulbs
clean air zone charges have come into
force in birmingham today
meaning that drivers of cars taxis and
vans that don't meet emissions standards
will have to pay eight pounds per day
with the zone
enforced 24 hours a day all year round
drivers of larger vehicles which don't
meet requirements like certain coaches
buses and hdvs
face having to pay 50 pounds a day
voters in switzerland have narrowly
rejected proposals to tackle climate
change
the measures were designed by the swiss
government to help meet targets under
the paris agreement
proposals included the introduction of a
car fuel levy
and tax on air tickets
elon musk has said that tesla will
resume
allowing bitcoin transactions when
miners use
more renewable energy in february tesla
said that it would accept bitcoin as
payment
but just a few months later announced it
would no longer be accepted
citing environmental concerns
marine biologists believe that rising
sea temperatures could be to blame
for a mystery skin disease that's
affecting white-tipped reef sharks in
malaysia
sharks have been appearing near
sipperton island
with spots and lesions on their heads
and attempting to diagnose what could be
causing the illness
scientists found the sea surface
temperature at cipden
had risen to 29.5 degrees celsius in may
that's a degree higher than in 1985.
now world leaders from the g7 countries
have agreed to
step up the action on climate change
after a three-day
summit in cornwall well the group has
committed to reaching
net zero no later than 2050
and to halve their collective carbon
emissions by 2030.
they've also promised to protect and
restore at least
30 percent of the natural world by 2030.
g7 leaders said that they will phase out
coal plants at home
and stop financing coal overseas and
they've agreed to meet an
overdue pledge to spend a hundred
billion dollars a year
helping developing countries cut
emissions and deal with global warming
but environmental campaigners say that
these promises lack
detail they've criticized g7 leaders for
failing to provide
any new commitments on climate finance
well with me now is assad raymond
director of war on wants it's an
anti-poverty
charity a good afternoon to you i said
um
the g7 says that it's pledging to build
back better would you agree
no i won't i think disappointment would
be an understatement
i mean just before the g7 met scientists
the un
said we're heading towards a point of no
return carbon emissions in 2021 are the
highest in a decade
climate impacts are affecting millions
and current pledges are so weak
and to be honest it seems like the g7
spent all their time
you know seeing that the house is on
fire and discussing what color to paint
the door
they on the critical issue of taking
responsibility and making the kind of
reductions that they needed it just
didn't go far enough they need to do
their fair share
2013 was a the target on the issue of
climate finance
that countries low-income countries have
been overwhelmed by
corvid and climate impacts etc we're
just rehashing the same broken promise
made
10 years ago for 100 billion and of
course that's just a drop in the ocean
climate scientists say we need about
three and a half trillion to meet the
1.5
it's there are estimates that we'd need
at least a trillion
if not more each and every year to build
that better so that we can have an equal
society for all
assad raymond really good to talk to you
thank you always a pleasure
now the head of the cbi says that the
corporate world is
way off track when it comes to tackling
climate change
tony danke has urged businesses to step
up
and drive the uk's transition to net
zero emissions
well it comes as some of the country's
fastest growing tech companies
have come together to launch a climate
action plan
the tech zero task force wants to help
firms become
net zero and offer their customers
greener choices well here to explain
more is hayden wood co-founder of bulb
and one of the tech
zero task force leaders good afternoon
to you
hayden i want to start by asking about
customers because you're in the energy
space
have you noticed that customers
attitudes towards where the energy comes
from has changed
hi sam thank you so much for having me
on uh the answer to your question is yes
we have noticed a huge difference
bulb was founded in 2015 and back then
less than one percent of homes were
purchasing energy from a renewable
supplier and
now that's up to 30 percent it could be
the growth story of the decade couldn't
it the green
revolution but why is the money not
coming through the door quicker
yes i think it could be the story of the
century but
um we are in we are in a bit of jeopardy
right now
it's a race against time to to fight
this climate crisis and we're running
out of time and we need to act
fast and move fast and that means that
you know thousands of thousands of
companies will need to change the way
they
uh work and operate uh millions and
millions of people will need to
uh change the the way they live and um
you're absolutely right that those
changes will require
innovation and investment in new
infrastructure
and the i guess the good news is that
those things are
starting to happen um but the um
it's incumbent on on all of us to uh to
make it happen
as you know as quickly as it needs to in
order to avoid temperature change
well i wish you all the best of luck
with it good to talk to you hayden wood
thank you
thank you now in central america the
major impact of climate change isn't a
future concern it is
already happening sarah ratate is
co-director of
ceres that's an organization that is
helping young people become community
leaders in sustainability
in guatemala and el salvador
i believe that climate change is the
moral test of our times
it's not just about the environment it's
about human rights
and justice it's about taking
responsibility for fellow human beings
and translating that into action
ceres operates in central america an
underdeveloped region
of the world that despite contributing
very little
to the causes of climate suffers some of
the worst consequences
last year in the midst of the pandemic
two
hurricanes hit the country can you
imagine
having to decide whether to save your
house and your crops
from the floods or whether you can
contract kobe at a shelter
our work supports young people from the
most vulnerable communities
to organize and begin to take action
to build resilience to protect our
ecosystems and to reduce
climate vulnerability just in the past
three years 50 000 young people
joined the movement every day working in
actions such as reforestation campaigns
educational environmental education
human rights
access to water food sovereignty and
many others
if the rest of the world could follow
their example
i know that we could achieve the 17
sustainable development goals
[Music]
inspirational stuff there well that is
everything from us for today coming up
tomorrow
it is global wind day we'll be finding
out about the future potential for wind
energy
around the world thanks as ever for
watching see you then